and you will see suddenly when the pies
crisis passes this bigger space in the
economy that government occupies won't
be ceded hello and welcome to
trigonometry I'm Francis Foster i'm
konstantine kisum and this is to show
for you if you want honest conversations
with fascinating people our brilliant
guests this week is a comedian author
and overall good egg dominic frisbee
welcome to trigonometry thank you very
much Constantine Thank You Francis thank
you I love the way you paused after
meters if you were considering whether
to thankfully what the pause was because
normally you you there's only one host
yes yeah I thought thank you constantly
Marissa he's there as well yeah bonus
was thought I introduced you you're a
man of many skills but one of the things
is an author and you are the author of a
book that's doing very well right now
which is this book here daylight robbery
yeah which is all about tax it is about
a riveting subject which may be dry but
you have managed to make it interesting
and before you tell us all about that
just tell everybody who are you how are
you where you are what has been your
journey through life okay and do I tell
you or do I go straight down the trellis
okay so I have a I'm 50 years old I'm a
Londoner I have quite an unusual
background in that I started out I went
to drama school when I was you know
after University and but the reason I
went to drama schools I thought all the
best writers started out as actors so I
sort of deliberately went to drama
school too almost trained as a writer
and then for some bizarre reason I was
the best radio in drama school and I got
a voiceover agent like almost before I'd
left drama school and found myself
straightaway doing voiceovers and
voiceovers is a very nice life it's
quite well paid and you're sort of
treated like royalty wherever you go and
you're looked after and you're not
treated like muck in the same way if
you're like a lowly comedian or a lowly
actor or something like that and so I
just sort of fell into doing voiceovers
and then in the late 90s I've written
this song called the upper-class
rap which was the idea was it was going
to be a novelty song that I wanted to
release for Christmas and I phoned up
this friend of mine who I knew was a
music agent an old University friend and
he said to me are now he he represented
the scissor sisters remember the scissor
sisters he said I can't be bothered with
this but go and try it my brother's Club
and his brother was Malcolm Hardee and
Wow yeah and so on and I remember as a
Sunday evening in 1997 and they used to
do they'd have the open spots and they'd
have two acts in the first after New
Haven until then they'd have the open
spots and the audience would always you
know be horrible to the open spots but
if you did well you got to pay booking
and the guy before me was a guy called
Knight who was not Knight Hovis Hovis
Presley sadly no longer with us but he
was brilliant and he was so funny and he
used to do these sort of lyrical
Lancastrian poems and in this sort of
lyrical Lancastrian voice and and the
reason I said knives is one of his lines
was my dog my mates got a dog called
Nigel talked about giving a dog a bad
name
I was remembered Nigel anyway and they
just were not having him in South East
London and and they were throwing things
at him but because he was very good and
he knew what he was doing he was
determined he just carried on and on and
on and by the time he'd finished I I
mean it was the first time obviously I
was ever performing but I'd never seen a
room in such total mayhem and Matt and
Malcolm just came on and said Roy our
next step is make me brothers areas
could be [ __ ] it's his first time on
stage and just introduced me on stage
like that and I borrowed my flatmates
pinstripe suit and I was going to head
out hello I'm the upper-class rapper and
all this and the audience just when they
just started it was like even more chaos
than it was when Nigel been on but for
certain but it was a wrap so they played
the music and I did the rap and I had no
I couldn't get involved in any banter
because it was just an act I just did
the act and they just eventually just
shut up and listened to it and found it
very funny and Malcolm just honored his
promise and gave me a paid gig the
following Friday and that went very well
so I got another paid gig and they
remember they said I think it's
little early to give you a pay twenty
given that it's only your second gear
but we will give you a paid ten and they
both went well and they just put Jane
then phoned up some other comedy clubs
around London East Dulwich tavern and
and comedy CAF and a couple of others
and said this guy is really funny she
give him things and suddenly I was a
stand-up comedian
I'll have times have changed young
comedians listen this is now going I've
been a comedian for three years I still
haven't got it ya know there's no
justice but we were just like they were
quite old school up the creek and there
were other clubs that would make you
jump through the hoops yeah like they do
now but but but at the creek in those
days were they honored their promise and
that was and yes so I found myself as a
comedian and then in the write-back the
mid naughties combination of whatever
I've made a bit of money and I wanted to
invest it sensibly and I started I met a
couple of people who fund managers and
so on and I just didn't like them as
something no you just don't learn
instinctively they want to take their
percentages and I just instinctively
didn't like them and you start reading
on the internet back then I was reading
all about gold and you think gold is
just you know jewelry whatever it is but
of course gold until the 20th century
was always money and so it's a very
political investment and I became
convinced that gold was a good
investment for one thing in another and
there were these really interesting
people talking about gold and a bit like
what you guys have done I was thinking
how do I talk to these people I don't
have to pay them two hundred pounds an
hour or whatever their fears to get
investment advice but I'd really like to
meet these people so I actually started
a podcast as a means to meet these
people and talk to I mean you as you've
probably discovered the best when you
have a do an interview with something
it's like that it's it's a heightened
conversation so you get in one interview
you get to know somebody much quicker
than you would if you just you know met
them for a cup of coffee know why we do
it but anyway I started this podcast and
I was interviewing all these you know
people talking about gold and learning
about the history of money and so on and
one of the people I interviewed was a
lady called Mary in Somerset Webb who
was the managing editor of of money
weekend so we spoke with her in
Edinburgh together didn't we yeah we did
her sharing we've since become great
friends but Mary said all we need people
like you to come write for
and by that they meant people who can
talk about finance without using
financial jargon and put it in a
language that you know isn't alienating
but is interesting to ordinary people so
suddenly I found myself with a column
for money week and then from there I
this other guy called Ross Ashcroft got
me to write this film for him called
four horsemen which became a big hit and
then so something I was like a financial
writer as well as being a comedian and
then I've written now three books all
about finance I wrote the first book
about Bitcoin way back when in 2014 and
I've always been very interested in in
the impact of our systems of money on
the way society works and you know
people try and explain how is it that
governments it's so big in our lives how
is it the government is 40 50 percent of
GDP wise you know wise government
everywhere and I used to it was because
once upon a time gold used to be money
and and you know gold put a discipline
on on governments they can only spend as
much money as they had gold it's a bit
more complicated than that but and so
that put a sort of restriction on how
big government could grow but of course
and in the First World War to pay for
the First World War the British American
and the British German and French
governments took their countries off the
gold standard in order to print the
money to pay for the war if they'd
stayed on the gold standard the war
couldn't have gone on for as long as it
did but they printed money and we went
into a system or what's called fiat
money where governments effectively
issue money and that has enabled
governments to just grow and grow and
grow so this is the reason we have such
large national debts and were able to
run run so basically it's the system of
money right it's inherently it's what's
called debt based fiat money that's
really interesting so if we were still
on a gold standard we would have to live
within our means much more yet well much
more and and that includes government's
yeah and all they go bankrupt but
because they have control them anyway
the bond markets it's a bit more
complicated than but but but basically
and so this was my big sort of theory
and then in about 2015 I sort of
developed the thing I was thinking no
it's not just money it's tax as well
taxes and and so I started reading about
tax and became slightly obsessed with
and did a show in Edinburgh called let's
talk about tax 2016 and it went very
well and I got
little Laurel for selling it out and did
you got a Laurel presumably for your eye
what's the sellout percentage that you
have a 93 percent or something I don't
know anyway I'm not sure okay it's funny
it's funny to me because you were very
enthusiastic about my show being
nominated for Best Newcomer sure it
would be and I told Simon Evans on a
mutual friend about this and he went
nominated you're lucky you didn't get
assassinated so I'm not sure I was gonna
get any kind of laurels for anything
well no but I think that the Laurel is
is not based on whether you've got the
right or wrong opinion I think it's
based on I think you had everything you
had a race based on whether you've got
the right anyway okay but Simon's very
realistic about those kind of things but
actually in terms of the money thing one
of the curious things about you is
you're someone who's been very wealthy
and you've also gone bankrupt on
certainly lost a lot of your my not gone
bankrupt sorry I don't mean just yeah
I've never gone bankrupt
I made it I've made a lot of money twice
yeah I've lost a lot of money yes how
did that happen well I don't really
wanna talk about that basically I made a
lot of money in gold well it all
collapsed in 2013 mining completely
collapsed and so you know all the money
I've made I effectively gave back and
then I was I was very early into Bitcoin
and so you know that was an
extraordinary opportunity but
unfortunately got hacked yeah and so I
had my Bitcoin stolen way way back so
you'd be like a super millionaire yeah
like I'm sort of I come to terms it now
but in 2016 2017 when Bitcoin went to
$20,000 I was like every night I was
having sleepless nights going oh my god
thank you you could like never have to
work again
yeah and retired yeah yeah that might
there's one thing I've always wanted to
do I've got this West End musical that I
want to put on and in order to put it on
I need like five probably five million
pounds and and you know so a lot of
money and the but I could have just like
I'm doing that really yeah and without
without it being an issue now I I think
you know that this story with Bitcoin I
bought half a Bitcoin yeah two hundred
pounds and then when it went up to four
hundred pounds I was like oh look I've
doubled
money and I sold it half a Bitcoin now
that's what like six grand
well actually the we're talking in the
midst of the coronavirus Oh yesterday
Bitcoin price had had a pretty bad day I
did it so it's probably only worth maybe
two three three thousand dollars now
sometimes all right so that's the
fluctuation is a huge if I had a Bitcoin
for every person that's told me a story
like that about how they sold too early
yeah I'd probably own the entire global
supply we've touched on Bitcoin so why
don't we talk about about crypto just
very very quickly because you were
triggered by I interview with Jim
Rickards
yeah yeah yes you got very upset with
Jim Beam he basically I haven't actually
seen the interview he did with you okay
but Jim and I had a big debate at kill
Konami
wasn't there but essentially we were
talking about it in the bar economics in
because Jim's position and I hope I'm
not misquoting he basically says that
it's it's a bit of a fraud yeah yeah
well it's not a bit it's a fraud he
thinks and it's a bubble and it's the
worst type of bubble you disagree with
that you put the case forward for
Bitcoin and crypto and why is it a good
thing well I would distinguish mean bit
coin and crypto because there are there
are lots of like okay so let's just
backtrack about bit every time you have
a new breakthrough technology you almost
always it is accompanied with a
speculative bubble so if you think of
the Internet
you know there was a huge rumbling
Comstock's and the story around the
internet was you know the internet is
going to change the world and that story
was right it is going to change the
world it did change the world but that
didn't stop loads of stupid speculative
money going in and you know how many
calm effectively scam companies there
were people raising money for just
ridiculous companies and so and you had
it with the railways for example in the
1830s and the 1850s in America in the UK
there were huge bubbles around railway
technology and you just always happens
you get a new technology and you know
everyone gets very excited about it and
it gets ahead of itself but you need
bubbles because bubbles
celery the investment so if we didn't
have that bubble in tech in 2000 you
know did all the you know the railway
tracks wouldn't have been laid that the
the cables wouldn't have been laid so it
accelerates investment so you know a lot
of people say our bubbles are terrible
now but what you have with Bitcoin it's
a new technology - breakthrough
technology but not only that it's a new
technology that is a new system of money
so if you were like a Marvel Comics
superhero designing like the ultimate
bubble would be Bitcoin and it there's a
finite supply of it so that again drives
up and puts a it increases the the
speculative potential of it and so it is
inherently bubbly and people get bit
cons a bubble they've been about maybe
five booms and busts in Bitcoin in the
ten years that it's evolved it is
inherently speculative and if you think
of all the you know they're known in the
crypto community as [ __ ] coins but if
you think all the [ __ ] coins that have
sprung up you know on the back of
bitcoins almost there's about 95% of
them are scams one way or the other so
there are loads of scams in the Bitcoin
space and then that there's the story
that Jamie Bartlett's thing did he did
on the radio about the crypto Queen you
know there was just a massive massive
scam and I believe the people that were
involved in that scam believed in it
when they were operating but that was a
sort of self delusion thing I think you
know the the best scam is actually
almost they kid themselves when there
when the performance yeah so when Jim
Jim says it is you know it is full of
scams and frauds and all the rest of it
but Bitcoin itself is not a fraud and
Jim has made a big mistake
Jim's you know you know he studies money
and has been writing about it Jim should
have just bought some bitcoins and and
because you just look at it and you go
it might not be but it has the potential
to be the default cash system of the
Internet and remember the the bought the
Internet is a borderless medium this
effectively and why is that Dominic what
makes Bitcoin so good for being the
exchange medium of the internet because
and I distinguish between cash and money
so if you if you go into a sweet shop
and you'd get your card out and you buy
whatever you buy in the sweet shop and
you go blue with your card that is not a
cash transaction because it involves a
card company in a bank and all sorts of
middlemen processing that transaction
and all these middlemen they take their
cut on the transaction and they all know
there is a record of that transaction
having taken place if I go into the
sweet shop and I you know buy a
newspaper whatever it is and I give the
newspaper man a pound or whatever the
cost of the newspaper is it is a direct
transaction cash transaction that
involves no middlemen and we need we're
going into this kind of cashless society
at the moment but we need cash you need
cash for small transactions for private
transactions for quick transactions but
especially you know illegal transactions
there are all reasons that's why you
need it and you know you can say well
cash is illegal but you can you can then
make the argument well know the law is
immoral it's not me that's buying weed
it's being immoral and using cash it is
the law making weed that it's immoral
and it's forcing me into an elite you
know so there's also it's not a cut and
dry thing but we need cash and above all
we need cash for privacy and to protect
privacy and Bitcoin is cash for the
Internet in other words if I want to
send money from me to you I can send it
directly from me to you with no
middleman and nobody else need to know
about that transaction and it can happen
privately it can happen instantly it can
happen for tiny amounts of money
fractions of a penny and and so that's
how it is cash but aren't all Bitcoin
transactions traceable they are they
every Bitcoin transaction is is
broadcast on the blockchain which is
effectively a huge database so you can
see that money this amount of money went
from this wallet with this address to
this wallet with this address right but
what you can't see is who know who owns
the two wallets so if you want to keep
your wallet address private then you
keep it private and then
you can keep it private there's also
things called Bitcoin mixers and all
sorts of little technologies that have
been added on which basically obfuscate
they put loads of transactions into one
thing muddled them all up and they so it
all gets obfuscated so that makes it
very hard to trace and where do you
stand on this argument that goes hang on
aren't you just encouraging the wild
west nature of the Internet you know
these nefarious people who want to know
trade and anything from you know drugs
to child pornography to whatever it is
and bitcoin is essentially aiding that
it certainly facilitates an age illegal
activity but if you look at the at
somebody's done a study on it and the
amount of bitcoins that are actually
used for the kind of transactions you
described it's like fewer than 2% or
something it's like an incredibly small
percentage we're delighted to have a
brand new sponsor for those of you who
are interested in learning a foreign
language might we've got predominately
British audience none of them are going
to be interested in learning a foreign
language yeah that's true also know
who's really traveling right now it's a
foreign country but when when the
coronavirus is over those of you who are
still left on this planet might be
interested in second language and that's
why Babel is a great place for you Babel
is great because they have a website and
an app which allows you to learn a new
language with 10-15 minutes snippets
every day in a clear and simple way
which is great for people like Francis
who are simple absolutely and also as
well when you're in quarantine what else
you gonna do you can try Babel
completely free simply head over to
babble dodo UK or download the app and
you can try it completely free that's
right guys go on to www.wymt.com
of tax in a way that gives you a
different perspective on it so yeah for
our viewers and listeners to whom that
may sound a bit of an alien concept just
give us some examples of what you're
talk so when I started writing this book
I did the show in 2016 and then that led
to a book deal and the the eye the
central thesis of the book is that
taxation is as old as civilization
itself there has never been in all
recorded history a civilization without
taxation of some kind and in fact
taxation probably predated civilization
in the hunter-gatherer societies before
human being settled in on the the
fertile plains between the Tigris and
the Euphrates there was probably already
existed this sense of duty to the
greater collective and that is the the
the central principle of taxation and
you know the very first taxes we have
were in ancient Mesopotamia and in fact
the very first examples we have of
ancient handwriting are tax records tax
documents and you can look at this you
know tax records are always historians
always look at tax records first because
they're for obvious reasons the best
preserved records because they're
records of debts and in all the time
since then there's never been a
civilization without taxation now
taxation can take various different
forms so you pay taxes in cash but in
you know in the ancient civilization
there wasn't necessarily money yet you
know so you might pay your taxes with a
share of your produce it's given and in
fact the very first ties were in ancient
Mesopotamia or a share of your labor or
so taxes not just taken in in cash
they're taken in the form of labor and
then you you have these sort of two
extremes where you might have a slave at
one extreme where a hundred percent of
that slaves labor is owned in fact the
slave has no ownership of nothing and
then the other extent if you have a
completely complete Anarchy with no no
government no leaders whatsoever then
and so total freedom nothing is taken
and so those would be the two extreme
but that society where nothing has taken
has pretty much never existed although
in ancient Greece quite interestingly in
ancient Athens before the Peloponnesian
War
taxes were voluntary oh really yeah so
it's like Greece now then so they'll
volunteer and how did it did people pay
them yeah the it was taxes were only
paid by the very rich and it was
expected that there was this sort of
culture of social duty and benevolence
in ancient Greek society and there was
this idea of that so if you think of
someone like Pericles you know King
Pericles they would if the if it was
deemed that the city needed a games or
it needed a new bridge or it needed a
new building built or needed a warship
or whatever it is it would be beholden
to the rich to pay for the construction
of that of further for those games or
for that building or for that bridge or
for that ship and not only would they
were expected to pay for it they would
be expected to carry out the that work
as well so rather than give your money
to a bureaucrat who gives it to a you
know a company that to do the thing that
person would carry and there they would
then put their own name on it so it
would be you know Pericles is bridge or
Pericles is building and many of you
know the greatest work buildings in
ancient Greece were built in this way it
was called liturgy the Parthenon
it's believed was built and you know
they provided the warships that
protected the Athenian shipping lanes
from Pirates and so on
Athens back then was a big trading
empire and because the rich person was
putting his name on it his reputation
was at stake
so the actual result was the obviously
often carried out the piece of work to
the highest possible standard because it
was his reputation is standing and would
often spend more than the minimum
whereas now we have this culture of you
know paying the least possible tax they
would often spend more because they
wanted to make sure it was done so thing
and it was just sort of this your kind
of social duty and funnily enough duty
we have this word duty duties actually a
it's another word for tax right so so
you have all these different but but
there has in all that time there has
never existed a society without taxation
of some kind so that was the first kind
of realization you know as as Benjamin
Franklin said you know taxes and death
are the two inevitabilities and actually
that phrase he wasn't the first person
to say that he's credited as being the
first person to say that but the the
first person to say that was actually in
a comedian in an early 18th century fast
called the cobbler of press F Preston
that this idea that these are the two
inevitabilities anyway and but you can
look back through history and you you
get this you suddenly realize that tax
is power if a king or a government or an
emperor whoever the leader is as as long
as they control that as soon as they
lose their tax revenue they lose their
power taxation is power it is control
and you you when you when you start to
look at things through that you know if
you imagine if governments today don't
have the tax revenue pretty quickly the
whole thing falls apart and you then
think every war in history was funded by
some kind of tax every single war you
tax during the event and then afterwards
you know the conquered territories would
be plundered and then taxed and often
wars were funded through debt but debt
is just a taxation on the future
I've regard debt as another form of
Taxation every revolution has been of
rising up a revolt against some kind of
injustice perpetrated by the tax system
the most famous ones being the French
Revolution the American Civil War no
taxation without representation even the
Russian Revolution American Revolution
yeah no that that was the the the the
u.s. American Revolution but even the
Russian Revolution now so you said
American Civil War that's what I'm sorry
the American Revolution and sorry that I
will always get that Russian Revolution
well that one well you're gonna know
more about it than I am highly well okay
but it was it was a it was an
overthrowing of serfdom effectively and
and serfdom was yet again a system of
taxing and rule serfs paid
they didn't necessarily pay cash but
their labor was owned and they paid
their labor and their labor was taken by
their lords and so on and and funnily
enough quite interesting serfdom was
overthrown in Western Europe the feudal
system was overthrown in Western Europe
by the Black Death because it killed
what to everyone out and suddenly there
was a shortage of labor and serfs were
able to demand their freedom and payment
for their labor and so even though you
know two-thirds of the population was
wiped out
it gave surfed and the freedom black
death never hit Russia in the same way
that it did Western Europe and so the
culture the the system remained and it
took you know the Russian Revolution to
get rid of it well there's a silver
lining to the coronavirus if two-thirds
of us are wiped out the rest of us might
have some better Buy well yeah that is
the there is that argument but it's not
one but so you know so then you think
every war every revolution every you
know even things like the birth of
Christ Mary and Joseph were only in
Bethlehem to pay taxes Chris Caesar
Augustus had issued a census and that's
why Mary and Joseph were in Bethlem if
it's if I call gustas haven't issued
that census
and by the way census where we get the
word censorship the sense or in ancient
Rome was the guy who adjudicated public
morality but he was also the tax
collector right and that and there's
always there's often been this moral
thing with taxes as I said we've
mentioned the word duty and we that
moral argument gets used in taxation
today it is your social duty to the
greatest collective to pay your taxes so
that we can have good health care and
welfare so but anyway Mary and Joseph
would not have been in Bethlehem were it
not to pay taxes effectively and without
that we would have Christianity would
never have evolved in the way that it
did Moses led the Jews out of Egypt to
escape the burden of Taxation that
taxation the the the persecution of the
Jews in ancient Egypt began with
taxation and then it eventually led to
slavery the reason that Jews were
enslaved was non-payment of taxes that
was the prisoners of war non-payment of
taxes were the ways that you could be
enslaved in ancient Egypt so effectively
Moses led the Jews out of Egypt and from
there we have the
10 commandments you know so there's a
tax story at that at the birth of
Judaism and by the way the persecution
of the Jews in in Nazi Germany began
with taxes as well um and in the
medieval kingdoms word shortly there
were all sorts of Jewish ties with
leather levied and even Islam there's a
tax story at the birth of Islam and it's
people can't understand how in from
between 660 and 690 in like the first
four or five caliphs from Mohammed and
then the first four caliphs Islam went
from being nothing to basically owning
most of the Middle East and both the
North Africa and then you realize they
had this policy of the countries they
conquered were heavily conquered end of
the Roman Empire sasanian emperors anti
an empire and people so heavily taxed
they have very little loyalty to their
existing rulers and they were just
grateful for relief from taxes and but
the there was a chap called Abu Bakkar
the first cat caliph and some of his
successors and they pursued a policy of
when they conquer people they gave them
exemption from taxation if they convert
it to Islam and if you didn't convert to
Islam you would have to pay poll taxes
and if you didn't pay the poll taxes you
had kilt so it was death taxes or Islam
which one are you gonna make absolutely
and then the early caliphs were
brilliant brilliant people so they had
this policy but they also had this idea
that they shouldn't burden conquered
nations with heavy taxes so for example
there was a bad weather then they would
say lighten the tax load let these
people be you know trade and get rich
because more money will if the people
are rich more money will eventually wake
it make its way to the extent that was
championed by economists like Arthur
Laffer later on and in hong kong and you
know the this idea that tax people less
and more money ends up making its way to
the exterior at the birth of islam even
something like you know 9/11 the twin
towers were built largely with tax money
first men on the moon were paid you know
nasa was a tax funded operation and you
just look at any event in history and
you'll suddenly realize that with
out this sort of untold tax story things
would have unfolded in a very different
way so we were talking about power now
to me it seems the government and any
government has to strike a very fine
balance like you said they need tax
revenue in order to keep going but if
the taxes are deemed to be unacceptable
or too high they can lose their power so
the last time I remember something like
that happening was the poll tax right
yeah only 90 year and in fact the the
sort of golden rule is that that
governments find it very difficult to
levy new taxes in times of peace so the
poll tax was what Thatcher was actually
attempting to do with the poll tax it's
quite interesting is she was trying to
bring more accountability to local
councils and make their out-of-control
spending more transparent and but what
ended up happening is is that the
out-of-control spending from local
councillors was so apparent because poll
taxes became so high so quickly that
everyone was at utterly outraged but
rather rather than having a go at their
local councils Thatcher was blamed
because she brought it in but
nevertheless and the poll tax brought
down Thatcher you know arguably the most
successful you know post-war politician
of the second half of the 20th century
maybe Tony Blair but you know as poll
tax brought it down and you know even
think's stupid things like you know
George Osborne's pasty tax and is man
and Ed Miliband's mansion taxes you just
don't get through in times of peace you
in order to get new taxes in you need
some kind of crisis usually a war and so
for example 2008 the financial crisis
gave us quantitative easing which is
another it's it's taxation by inflation
Milton Friedman called inflation
taxation without legislation but but it
you know you need you know if the idea
of printing money and quantitative
easing in zero interest rates if there
wasn't a financial crisis in there the
global financial system wasn't about to
implode everyone again what no and and
so World War two prior to World War two
ordinary Americans didn't pay income tax
it was only the richest Americans that
paid in realized 1942 revenue act
brought income tax to ordinary Americans
for the very first time similarly in the
first
or the British income tax had just
existed but it was only the very rich
that paid it an ordinary British people
did not pay income tax until the First
World War and suddenly with the First
World War time of crisis funding the
soldiers of good thing women come into
the workforce and bizarrely that's
another one where people talk about
women being given the vote now one of
the core arguments in the women being
given the vote in after the First World
War was the fact that women had paid
taxes during the First World War because
they were all now working and that was
justification as to why women should be
given the vote so even it's something
unconnected like the suffragettes
there's a tax story there but ordinary
Americans did not pay income tax until
1942 and there was a the 1942 Revenue
Act and in order to like persuade
Americans that it was their patriotic
duty to pay there was all sorts of like
Donald there was a film commissioned
from Walt Disney that had Donald Duck
paying his income tax really Hanford
showing him how to fill out the form
Irving Berlin was commissioned to write
a song called I paid my income tax today
and it contains the line a thousand
planes to bomb Berlin they'll all be
paid for and I chipped in see those
bombers in the sky rockefeller helped to
build them so did I and was ever the tax
the link between tax and war more
apparent I don't think you could get
away with that now could you absolutely
you know every battle of fallujah was
funded by me you know that was that was
the mentality yeah and in fact every
conquest as well as been about taking
control of the tax base the land the
labor the produce the profit so but so
you need a crisis to introduce new
levels of tax but what happens after the
crisis passes is that taxation never
goes back to the levels that it was
before the crisis began after the first
world war after the Second World War for
example you know the wounded have got to
be helped we had the birth of the NHS we
had so a land grab goes on in a time of
crisis where government seizes some kind
of control and then never gives it back
afterwards
and the IFS causes that the ratchet
effect and so if you when you try and
figure out how it is that
government you know if you think that in
1900 government was about 10-15 percent
of GDP in the UK now it's more like 45
50 percent same and all across Western
Europe France is like government
spending is like 56 percent of GDP and
the juillet Jean there's another example
of another tax rebellion oil taxes and
this this this uprising in Lebanon was
about taxes on whatsapp they've tried to
levy attack every time you make calls on
whatsapp and send taxes on whatsapp they
tried to levy attacks and cause a
rebellion so um so you need a crisis and
coming back today we've got this
coronavirus crisis going on I promise
you and the government has spent all
this pledges bailing out and fiscal
stimulus and all the rest of it it's a
land grab going on and you will see
suddenly when the price crisis passes
this bigger space in the economy that
government occupies won't be ceded the
Tories are supposed to believe in
limited government but no they don't
yeah yeah they're just Social Democrats
buying on the name and so that's what we
will see in this crisis now that's very
interesting because we're under
austerity there was they put the vit up
to 20% didn't they and did they have a
reverse here is it still at 20%
they've halted tax is now a little bit
there's no extra for that we just had
the budget this week and there's very
few extra taxes on things like alcohol
the sin taxes have being flattened as
little but but but you know this is one
of the big arguments that's going on in
Europe is in order to get legislation
through the EU they have to have 100%
agreement amongst the Member States and
they're trying to harmonize taxes they
want higher levels of that they want to
introduce financial transactions tax
they want to introduce digital taxes but
they can't get it through because they
need the agreement so they're trying to
change the European Constitution to just
a majority and they use Younker and
various others use all sorts of the most
Orwellian language to describe you know
for the common good this this we don't
need majorities anymore and without a
total majority you know that smaller
EU member-states will get shafted by
greater taxes so the you know but as
soon as the EU start setting taxes
rather than individual nation states
then the whole power structure of Europe
changes you can see Dominic is the
author of the song 17 million fun locks
the success of break break says yeah
that song did very well didn't it yeah
it did it was my hit hmm it got to
number 43 in the chance not not quite a
hit it needs to be top 40 to be a hit
but yeah it was I wrote it in March just
before we were supposed to leave and
didn't March 2019 and and then we did
and I did a new verse after the general
election in December
well I remember actually at on breaks a
day I turned on the TV to watch serious
sky news coverage of the event and it
was just loads of people in the
background go [ __ ] along to the music I
don't think I will ever have a better
moment to perform that song on brexit
night in Parliament Square somewhere
between fifty and a hundred thousand
people and just singing that song I'll
never just like I'll never do such a big
and memorable gig and but the really
funny thing about that gig is the the
idea is is you know you list all the
things that they said would happen if
you voted to leave there'd be food food
shortages and riots and and you know no
sandwiches and there'd be an outbreak of
super gonorrhea and all these stupid
things they said would happen quite for
that reason but anyway all these things
would happen and and the English told
them to [ __ ] off and that was the the
catch phrase but I was told if I sang
the English if I said the word farc in
Parliament Square on on this thing I'd
be done for a public order offence so I
so I said to the audience I don't want
to get arrested I don't want to get land
you know the organisers of the event in
trouble so I'm going to say fudge and so
every time the thing comes like oh the
English told them to fudge off but you
can all sing the lyrics as they were
originally written and I don't think
they're going to they can arrest
thousand of you so the audience all just
sang it and there's this as you said
this is hilarious interview with Nigel
Faraj where he's trying to do an
interview with sky from the thing
well I'm singing the song in the
background and all you can hear is the
English told you to [ __ ] off the English
told you to [ __ ] off and Nigel Farage
gay it's very difficult to hear it's
very wonderful thing and he can't hear
cuz all he can hear and everyone's
trying not to laugh is there a tax
dimension to brexit well yes I very much
think so firstly that thing I described
it yeah of the your European trying to
be you trying to harmonize taxes is one
danger and you know centralised power in
effectively and Brussels and brexit was
a vote against that centralization but I
hoped that you know I voted for brexit
mainly because I'm a libertarian and I
believe in as little government as
possible and it removes a layer of
government effectively but my hope
perhaps a little naively was that it
would lead to a sort of most
libertarians voted for babies are quite
a few didn't but I think the majority of
libertarians were in favor of it and we
were hoping that it would lead to a much
reduced government in the UK and a much
freer you know sovereign Society but
that doesn't appear to be the case so
Dominic you see say that you're a
libertarian and that you would prefer
smaller government lower intervention
lower taxes can you make the case for
libertarianism and why you believe in
smaller government because if you look
at all throughout history the happiest
the most inventive the most innovative
the most wealthy societies the greatest
societies in history have always had
very high levels of freedom you know
whether it's the early Roman Republic or
ancient Athens or the greatest societies
that freedom reduces as the society
evolves but even you know Britain in the
second half of the 19th century was sort
of Britain's golden era was a very low
tax Society early America you know the
Great America of extremely low taxes AIA
tea in the second half the
nineteenth and early twentieth century
and so the central case for
libertarianism and then if you look at
the the opposite of that and you look at
the societies that have had very high
levels of government
high levels of taxes low levels of
freedom and by the way there is a
relationship between taxation and
freedom the less tax you pay the more
free you are because the more of your
own labor you own and the more economic
freedom you can't have freedom without
economic freedom as a Thatcher line and
so the central core is the less tax we
pay the freer we are the more free we
are to experiment with our money with
our ideas with our thought you know all
you guys are big free speech guys it's
all part the same thing free speech free
movement free trade it's all part of the
same you get all these guys are in favor
of free speech but not free trading it
come on it's free everything and you
that you have the greatest level of
freedom but you also have the greatest
levels of individual responsibility
individuals are much more accountable
for their own actions for their own
choices and as a result they tend to
behave better and they tend to act in a
way that benefits themselves and also as
a result benefits the greater good and
so the greatest societies in history
have always been low tax libertarian
type societies what about Scandinavia
cuz everyone always bangs on about how
they've got this utopian society with
high levels of tax and wealth
redistribution they do and it's the core
argument that's always used a champion
Scandinavia but I don't think scan and
aether is a particularly happy place at
the moment particularly Sweden and
Sweden's had all sorts of problems but
what's Scandinavia gets right and I
think there's a thing in Scandinavia
there's a there's well let me just
describe what Scandinavia gets right in
its tax systems is tax a much higher
percentage of taxes are levied locally
where there is far greater
accountability so people can see that
the taxes they pay they can see the
immediate consequences of it and they
can hold the people who are spending
their money badly to a much greater
account
so whereas
in the UK for example tap much higher
percentages are levied centrally and
there's much less accountability so I
think people are happier to pay higher
levels of taxes when there is greater
accountability for the money and how
it's spent and there's a more clear
visible effect between me giving this
money and being able to see how that
money was used and the the Balmer the
bombs that it was spent on but the other
thing that I think exists in
Scandinavian countries and I think it's
is almost the weather that breeds this
and you get it I'm you probably get it
in northern Russia I'm not sure don't
know enough about it be sooner get it in
Canada where there's this thing of if
you do not prepare for the winter oh
yeah you die oh yeah
so that breeds a sort of responsibility
and a preparation and a collectiveness
that maybe doesn't exist so much in say
southern Europe or where it's hotter
where there tend to be much more lace a
fair and and and so it it's sort of
almost the weather creates a culture and
so this culture of social responsibility
and individual responsibility exists in
the Scandinavian countries that maybe
isn't as prevalent further south I know
this is a question that I've always
wanted to ask you Dominic so you're
libertarian small-government low
intervention what about the NHS the NHS
a National Health Service is not the
best means in my opinion to provide the
highest standard of care to the most
possible people at the lowest possible
cost and nor is state education the best
means to provide the best possible
education there's so much waste in the
NHS it's a it's just so big and bloated
it's so hard to run and if you look at
areas of the economy where it's pretty
much a free market you know they're not
provided by the state you look at
something like food for example the food
revolution that's happened in the UK now
food is as essential as good health care
is essential to our survival but food is
largely not provided by government and
you just see the market at work in the
food industry we've got the most
incredible variety of food now the
highest the worse wonderful quality you
could find fault with in because I don't
like supermarkets under like this you
can find faults with stuff but there is
so much choice and the cost of food on a
relative basis like food clothing and
accommodation made up over 50% of a
workers outlay well I think it was like
80% 100 years ago something like that
food clothing and accommodation now food
clothing food clothing and
accommodations a much lower portion
about 15 to 20 percent of somebody's out
there's something like that maybe
accommodation a bit higher and but they
didn't have the most expensive purchase
you ever make as your government of
course which is like over fifty percent
of everything you ever earn will end up
in the government over the course of
your entire life
and so anyway you look at something that
is provided largely by a free market
food clothing we've got a credible
choice and you know I know we have food
banks and so on but really nobody needs
to go hungry you know you can buy for a
pound you can buy an incredibly the
ingredients to make an incredibly
healthy vegetable soup or whatever it is
that would have been a luxury 100 years
ago and the problem with the National
Health Service is it is run not for the
benefit of the consumer ie the patient
it is run largely for the benefit of the
supplier and whereas if you think you
know you go into a shop you don't like
the service you get in the shop you
don't have to go to that shop you can go
to another shop or you can leave that
shop a bad review or you can not pay the
the restaurant you know the the shop is
so desperate for your custom or the
restaurant so they've they will try and
give you the best possible service or on
that dynamic doesn't exist in the
National Health Service and it should in
the 19th century we had the friendly
societies and M much more insurance
based system of health care and doctors
were employed by local communities and
if that doctors they did the doctors
didn't like what the doctor was doing
local communities he was held
accountable to the local community and
they could sack it and and employ other
one that same dynamic just doesn't exist
within the NHS
it's so rife with protectionism and
special interest groups it is a it is an
absolute mine of crony capitalism
there's so much corruption landing these
contracts and you get these stupid
situations where I'm gonna get the
figures exactly wrong but you know some
companies finding a way of charging the
NHS 10 pounds per packet of paracetamol
whereas you look at the what you know
paracetamol in the free market you can
buy it for 20 P they subsidiaries being
build these amounts and all these
inefficiencies that just wouldn't happen
if if if small companies were running
individual businesses within the NHS on
a profit and loss basis where they had
to take much greater account of of waste
so it's just not the best way to provide
the best possible health care at the
lowest possible cost
now people go if we didn't have an NHS
then people would go untreated and I
just don't believe that because let's
say health care wasn't provided by the
state and he'd go back to a 19th century
you know he'd you if the state wasn't
providing health care we would all have
to take precautions to look after our
own health care and provide for it not
just for ourselves but for other people
in the community as well and so you'd
have you know I I envisage if there was
no health care and this is ideal
idealistic chap because the idea of
getting away getting rid of the NHS is
just not realistic but you know people
would have greater responsibility to
look after their own lives look after
their own health provide for their own
health care and provide for their health
care of others in their community as
well and you know it's it's you'll never
prove it because you can't prove
something that's not going to exist but
if if if government didn't provide
health care I believe that health care
services and health care provision would
see would be as advanced and as
brilliant as food and clothing but the
obvious counter example to that would be
the United States where people do go on
no it's not the obvious counter the
United States spends almost twice as
much for the United States government
spends almost twice as much on health
care per capita as the UK government
does the United States government is
this kind of mix is this crony
capitalist mixture of an insurance based
system
mixed with it's just horrendous and it
is the worst possible outcome and you
know far better systems is I think
Switzerland New Zealand France they all
have insurance based systems that work
much better than ours do you got and
what is an insurance based system for
the people who don't know well the what
the friendly societies did in the in the
second half of the nineteenth century
it's as you know it was a huge economic
boom it was the greatest one of the
greatest periods of wealth creation ever
ever known so the greatest wealth growth
ever seen and in local communities
workers would put in a portion of their
money they would give to what was their
friendly society like the court the coop
was a friendly society and they would
put a portion of their earnings and they
would have there would be local
communities local friendly societies and
then that friendly society would then
provide the health care you know would
employ the doctors employ the nurses and
whatever wherever else was needed and
then and in times of emergency you know
there would be that five pounds that
they'd put in of there about five
percent of their earnings or whatever
they put in would be their insurance in
the case of and the the community would
decide you know well that's this is
francis he's been putting money in this
thing all this time he's a good guy you
know we need to help him oh this is
Constantine Constance is lost his job is
lost there and so welfare was was and
health care was provided on a mutual
basis locally and it meant there was
much greater flexibility so you know if
Constantine's a barman he never does the
work and and and he needs to kick up the
bum then that's rank kind of welfare and
if Francis is a good guy and actually he
needs to be you know have an arm round
and then be stroked but so there's just
much more flexibility whereas what well
now our system of welfare is like a
top-down one-size-fits-all so and that's
that's how much insurance worked and it
was so successful that Lloyd George and
Winston Churchill in the National
Insurance Act of nineteen eleven tried
to copy it
on a national level so they this they
introduced national insurance and people
will put in a portion of their earnings
into the insurance system and as a
result if they needed emergency
healthcare or anything else that came
out of the National Insurance the
problem was people couldn't afford or
didn't chose not to pay national
insurance and for their local thing they
were effectively buying it twice
national insurance was compulsory the
local one wasn't and so they had to
carry on paying the local one and then
the national one and the local ones will
went out of business so it was a
free-market evolution that was so
successful the government copied it and
then messed it up and today the money
you pay international insurance should
be there for you to call on in an
emergency but it isn't because the
government spends it now if a
corporation did that they you know it's
what Robert Maxwell did it's effectively
fraud but governments it's different
rule
well that's nicely summed up Dominic our
final question is always what's the one
thing that we're not talking about the
we ought to be talking about I think the
one thing we're not talking about slowly
starting to talk about it is race and
racism
what is racism because we have had these
you know accusations thrown about
so-and-so is racist now what actually is
what actually is racism you know if a
and I say this as you know somebody was
my kids are all mixed-race not all
actually two of them a mixed-race um
what define not is is racism actively
going and persecuting somebody on
account of their race that's what the
transformation of the law is
accidentally using the wrong word right
well the transformation over the last
ten years on that issue has been
incredible racism used to mean prejudice
against people on the basis of those can
yeah now it means you said something
that people can misinterpret if they so
choose yeah I mean you you're racist if
you lose the long words but the wrong
words but I just think we're all
prejudiced we all the constant you know
a discriminating gentleman used to be a
good thing now if you're discriminating
it's it's about
think but you know I'm constantly making
judgment all the way through having a
conversation with somebody or having a
relationship whenever you're constantly
making judgments on whatever level they
operate the relationship works now you
make judgments based on how they look
how they sound all sorts of different
things and what are we just supposed to
just ignore the fact that this guy is a
different race to you and we're just
supposed to pretend that there aren't
different races because there are and
different different races different
counts everyone has different
characteristics they just do and I just
think there's a dishonesty to the whole
argument whereas we're so scared of
being called racist that we just
airbrush the whole thing and pretend
that nothing exists that there's no and
so the sooner we can acknowledge that
make the acknowledging that people are
different doesn't mean you are going to
actively go out and persecute that
person on account of their race Isis on
the Domenic getting cancelled I guess
let's explore that because I think it's
a really fascinating conversation I
guess the argument would be that we've
decided to be hypersensitive about race
because we went through periods in
history where there was a lot of
stereotyping of people based on their
ethnicity or race which was used to then
discriminate against those people yeah
so the idea would be you know as you say
we all have our biases but the idea
would have been in the past that a lot
of people would have said well black
people are all lazy right which then
would prevent a particular black person
who was really hard-working right from
being seen for who they actually are as
opposed to being seen through the prism
of their land of the race so this is in
color right so you know that I think we
would all agree is a positive that we
moved away from judging people in this
broad broad categories right what we
agreed on that yeah yeah yeah so what
are you saying exactly because I don't
want people to take what you've said out
of context or to misunderstood
and the the the the crime of racism the
sin of racism whatever you like has been
totally undermined by overuse of the
term absolutely and just dishing it out
and just going oh well the sensor
doesn't agree me they're racist yeah and
they can smear somebody with that and
it's like the work once you've got the
racist label like many people just have
never recovered doesn't wash off it just
yeah it doesn't never and and you know
lives have been ruined and they've kind
of been smeared with this thing and it's
a terrible thing to do to somebody like
that you get all these and but the the
whole the the problem now with racism is
there's so much protection has gone on
that it's just created so many special
interest groups campaigning for you know
it's not just a race thing it's just any
type of identity is demanding that it's
got whether it's trans or or or is
Islamic group or a black group or a
white or whatever and now we've got this
thing where there's almost like a white
wipe I've just written a song about this
very thing called I am a white man and
I'm sorry
and and it's like there's loads of white
people are just going a complaining that
they're victims of racism and they are
because they're being overlooked in
favor of the jobs or whatever it is
because somebody's got to tick this
ethic and so it's just this insane
culture of special interest with yes and
I just think like I think they're a vet
they're a might you know be people who
go you know we always go I don't know I
hate scousers you go to Liverpool and
you know some scouts place horrible to
you and you got [ __ ] eights couses and
it's one of those things that you might
say or you know and I hear northerners
coming down to like a [ __ ] eight
companies you just you know whatever and
they're all definitions they now that is
racist according to today's terminology
but just because you know I've gone off
you know or I go to France and there's a
huge queue and passport control or
something on our [ __ ] French whatever
that's a effectively a racist thing to
say now but inside
I'm not advocating the persecution of
scousers or northerners you come to
London and moan about colonies not
advocating the persecution of cotton is
there just one of those things that you
say so I think we just need to be more
transparent understand what is racism
which to me is is the systematic
persecution of people on account of
their thing and what is just normal
human behavior we've got nothing to
worry about
we're as pure as driven snow producers
scouser so we're fully in favor right
you know I'm immune from all charges
because of a racial makeup of my family
but but but you know it doesn't get me
off with my brand mother Venezuelan
model but he actually married a woman of
a different color to every time someone
accuses you just bring out a photo yeah
I know yeah that's the way out of it but
dominate I've been given immunity yeah
you have they just make sure you've
always got one with you at all times but
she would I mean we're not married
anymore but she would have a go at me
yeah on account of my you know race
color background age and I would do the
same to her and it and now we're no
longer married justify you take my point
that yeah it's just like we if we it's
it's everyone is so uncomfortable with
it
that it just makes them freeze and that
is just not healthy you know I'm it's
and it's because of this sort of culture
of special interest groups
I remember that many years ago now that
if and if when I'm about to describe it
it will feel like it was 50 years ago
but I think it was only in the mid
naughties at the very latest there was a
Conservative MP who'd been in the army
who made some comments about it remember
this he said that you know there's a lot
of banter happen that happens in the
Armed Forces so if you were ginger when
people were making fun of you they would
call you a ginger bastard yeah and if
you were black they would call you a
black bastard and everybody accepted it
as part of the culture anyway and he'd
got instantly destroyed had to resign
all this kind of stuff I think that is
what you're saying
I am and like I remember being in a pub
and this would have been probably early
noughties something like that and being
in a pub and I was watching a football
game in the pub and Andy Cole
it was Man United were playing an Andy
Cole missed a really goalie should have
scored as he was prone to do it and
there's a bloke watching the telly in
the pub and he's selling oh you black
[ __ ] he says that now is that is that
racist I think in 2020 that were okay
extreme that's what he says yeah okay
then Schmeichel the goalie yeah
let's in a goal then I should say and
the same guy goes you blond bastard
right is that racist there Andy Cole and
you know they're both a [ __ ] and a
bastard because they've not done what
the fan was hoping they would do on the
football pitch okay they're not it's
Michael's not a bastard because he's
blond he's a bastard because he's a guy
he's a bastard who happens to be blond
who's he's a boss because he's letting
the goal in he happens to be blond Andy
Cole is not a company's black he's a
[ __ ] because he's missed a goal and he
happens to be a black guy right okay now
here's the clincher of this story it was
a black guy who said it mmm-hmm it was a
black guy who called a Nicola black can
suddenly breathe again
[Laughter]
like just in having this conversation
yeah yeah and I can sort of almost
regret already having this conversation
because I can see it dramatically
backfiring but you know just in having
we can't even talk about this and this
is a cut you know and so but so it's a
black guy calling a Nicola Brothers
really interesting and there's so many
more moral questions there and it's it's
you know and even the guy even if the
guy who said it was a white guy and he
call him a black car he's not advocating
the persecution of black people he's
just he's just going are you black can I
guess my sense of that situation nearest
effective of who's saying is how is the
bluntness of color relevant to the fight
so just lasted that if it's it was you
know a defining carry sister to right so
this is what I'm saying is maybe the
some of the progress we have made that's
been good is that we avoid judging
people in these group categories when
it's not relevant to the to the thing at
hand like candy Cole [ __ ] up
Schmeichel [ __ ] up do we need to bring
the skin color or hair color into it
maybe we just leave it out do well yeah
but then that's that sense that's well
that's a form of censorship and it's a
it's it and you can choose as an
individual anguish sense of that and you
can self sense it but that's just an
individual using its judgment not all
I'm saying is maybe in that situation we
we learn not to make an issue of those
things when it's not relevant that's all
you're saying yeah but I just like it
yeah I guess so
I mean I don't I think a society in
which everyone goes around calling each
other black [ __ ] is proper white [ __ ]
whatever is probably not it's probably
not a good thing but it's a football
match yeah I'm in the realest it's in a
pub you know it's that's when that
that's I'm in a real lesson here is just
never to watch mine United there was the
city player Bernardo Silva yeah who got
done earlier this season for calling the
was it mehndi Benjamin many the black
left bat Portuguese guy joke that Mende
look like yeah it from Spain yeah but
they were like mate when they found it
very funny yeah yeah it's like me going
to you you look like whoever yes like
Francis saying we're gonna deport you
back to Russia I don't take it
personally because did you yeah earlier
than didn't he got banned at me and it's
just a stupid like that is people seeing
racism where it yeah yeah all right
anyway let's [ __ ] end it now waiting
with this little wide skin yeah guys buy
this book it's great Dominic's gonna
need the proceeds winning it cap
daylight robbery brilliant book about
taxation make sure you get it and we
will see you in a week from now with
another brilliant episode if we're still
here yeah take it take care see you next
week guys thanks for watching guys as
always subscribe to the YouTube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out and follow us on all the
social media at trigger pot and also
leave us a nice review on iTunes and
spread the word